good morning
good morning I'm Vincent Garnier the
director general of the ftth council
Europe
I'm very happy to welcoming you on this
webinar titled sustainability a global
view from the fiber to the home Council
Global Alliance and I will immediately
give the floor to the moderator of this
session uh Juanita if you want to to
start
morning thank you thank you Vincent and
your good morning colleagues and welcome
to the session as Vincent mentioned my
name is Juanita Clark I'm the chief
executive officer of the digital Council
Africa and a member of the fiber to the
home Council Global Alliance or the fcga
is probably more how you know it
um and yeah I look forward to moderating
the session this morning
um so today we like really excited to
present to you our latest Market survey
themed sustainability a global view
so for those that don't know the FCC
ftth Council Global Alliance or fcga is
a is a global platform that was created
more than a decade ago
um and this platform exists for the
regions to collaborate and cooperate and
there's six Regional members that are
active and those members of North
America latam Latin America
Mena the middle eastern North Africa
ourselves sub-Saharan Africa Europe and
then Asia Pacific and all these ftth
councils share a one common goal and
that's to accelerate the adoption of
fiber to the home Technologies and we
all act independently
but we um and we've got a strong focus
on our regional uh you know activities
but this Regional Focus gives every
single one of the organizations a
special strength to adapt their
activities to their specific Market
situation in their area
but the fcga ensures that all these
Regional efforts are combined with the
power of global cooperation we often
engage with each other we've got a
monthly meeting where we discuss our
regions the activities in our regions
and progress within regions
um we share thoughts ideas
um and and more than that within the
fcga the respective councils also
exchange studies information and of
course our latest Market developments
um so as mentioned as part of the fcga
efforts we take on annual studies and
initiatives that we believe are of
interest to our members and to the
industry at large
um and often the governments that we
engage with it's a big privilege today
to report on the latest body of work
that we've done globally and we're going
to today present to you the results of
the global sustainability survey after
we present these results we'll just have
a brief panel discussion with the
leadership of the fcga to discuss the
regional differences of the results I
just wanted to mention that of course
because of the time zone differences
the Gary Bolton who's the president and
CEO of the of the fiber Broadband
Association as well as our colleague
from latam cannot beer there is a
another session today at 5 00 PM CST if
you want to share that with your
colleagues in other parts of the world
they're welcome to attend that and of
course we're happy to send them a link
for that session
um but yeah so the structure for today's
session and that we will start with
Vincent Garnier the director general of
the fdth council Europe and he's Vincent
is also the 2023 chair of the fcga
and he's going to walk us through a
brief presentation of the result of the
the survey
um and at the conclusion of Vincent's
presentation I will invite all the
regional leadership
um today uh joined
byham from Mina Andrew safia Lam from
APAC and they're going to then join me
as we then engage in a panel discussion
um but yeah thank you I really hope you
enjoy it and
um we'll also you're welcome to please
make comments um in the site chat any
questions that you type will be picked
up by us and we will then handle that on
an adult basis but please also let us
know where you're from where you're
joining from and which company you
represent but good morning everybody and
welcome I'm currently Nairobi in Kenya
so as we say here Jambo karibu which
means welcome and hello it's good to
have you with us so with that Vincent
I'm going to hand over to you
well thank you very much ranita and good
morning everyone
so the objective of the this quick
survey was to have a understanding as
much as possible of the overall
organizational awareness about company
policies and sustainability goals among
our ecosystem
and I would start with a brief
presentation of the methodology for for
this survey it has been conducted at the
end of last year it concerns both a
company which are members of our
organization of the different Council
but also more largely we extended the in
the inquiry the the survey to all
contacts within our reach and our
database in total we had 150 respondents
with a good mix between Network
operators vendors and others actually I
can share with you a more detailed
representation of
the the breakdown of respondent by
geography and by organization type so as
you can see on the left side of this
chart
North America and Europe have been well
represented
to a lesser extent Latin America but in
proportion with which are quite typical
for this kind of survey the region which
are less represented in this survey are
Mina but most importantly Asia Pacific
so I would say this is the major uh
methodology ba we have in our survey we
we've not been able to capture enough
answers from the Asia Pacific creation
so our region so I would caution uh any
interpretation of the number concerning
Asia Pacific but surely when it comes to
Europe North America and Latin America
we we think we have an interesting uh
representation of what our industry
thinks and also because we were able to
capture feedback from both a network
operator which made half of the
respondent a quarter were vendors and 22
percent were not defining themselves so
are likely to be either
um contractors or maybe
um people being either from Network
operator or from vendor but not
identifying themselves as such
now
um we have also
um asked questions we were which which
were beyond the the theme of
sustainability covering what is now
known as being either CSR or ESG so
before we move further just a quick
reminder of what is behind both acronyms
actually corporate social responsibility
is a concept which started quite a few
years ago which was used to define
all areas of
importance for the a company for a
commercial organization Beyond its core
goal to maximize shareholder value and
and address the needs of its clients so
it was about integration with a larger
ecosystem that a company should pay
attention to its people the environment
but also the society around the company
at the time of the CSR it was
aspirational it was about setting up
culture putting this this element on the
map whereas now we are talking about ESG
environmental social and governance
which is uh something we want to measure
in much more concrete way so with ESG
com metrics accountability and these
data are increasingly taken into account
by investors when they are defining
their investment strategy they are
considering ESG performance of company
they want to invest in so this is where
we are now
additional element we took into account
in our survey were concretely reduction
of greenhouse gas emission and carbon
footprint
of on the
governance side the concept of employee
advancement
and also to what extent developing and
improving sustainability program uh are
put in place
another element of the survey
um
which was
identifying the different question was
about what you can see here on the slide
the detailed question about employee
advancement the different format of
reporting and how these objectives are
clearly defined through targets and
initiative
and before I present to you the the main
results and the key takeaway from the
survey I would like to launch a poll and
to just assess
um among you
um
whether or not
your company have a ESG or CSR strategy
so I hope you can
um yeah see the poll coming up on your
screen I give you a few seconds to to
answer the poll
um
it's very simple yes no we're working on
it or I don't know I see that we start
to collect answers from from the
audience thanks a lot for for your
participation this is great
um
and I think we are getting close to
um all participants having
um answered I give you a few more
seconds
and I will close the poll to share the
results
back to you so okay let's close the poll
I hope you can see the result
are we sharing the result
um can come someone confirm that to me
no we don't you just have to share them
um
yeah I'm I need to get used to to the
platform I think we see the result yeah
and interestingly a majority of you
are clear about the fact that your
organization has a ESG CSR strategy uh
23 percent uh are working on it and only
a tiny minority is not aware of the
situation or has no such strategy
I think the fact that we are
presenting this present this this
webinar on time zone compatible with uh
Europe participants
um probably explain this result and I'll
show you later in in a few seconds to
what extent it matches the result of a
survey so thanks very much for your
participation I now
moving back to
um
to the deck
and I hope
okay so yeah those are two holding
slides
um so the the key finding
um coming out of this survey are first
if we try to define the common themes we
found across all region I must say it
was not a very easy exercise because
there there are big differences between
region nevertheless we have highlighted
four things first one is supporting
customer
um
gas emission
um greenhouse gas emission Reduction
Program through the life cycle
assessment methodology was actually
cited by many respondent
the the concept of converting from hfc
Network to ftth network was also seen as
part of the program to improve
sustainability
the goal to of 40 reduction in
greenhouse gas emission by 2030 with the
long-term Global goal of Net Zero carbon
neutrality by 2040 was also found in a
variety of answers
and finally Financial Security ranked
the lowest in employee deployment
initiative across origin while Health
well-being safety ethic and integrity
ranked the highest
so these are for the common takeaway we
could see across the board
and when it comes to more specifically
ESG and CSR strategy and sustainability
you will see the next chart that Europe
is far ahead of other region Latin
America ranks second and North America
Amina and APAC are clearly lagging
behind
and here is here are the results uh on
the first question we asked to you a few
minutes ago
um has your company has your
organization an ESG or CSR strategy here
we see that in North America 72 percent
of the respondents say no
in Latin America this is more balanced
because an equal proportion say yes
compared to the one saying no at 42 45
percent whereas in Europe you see the
the symmetrical picture compared to the
situation in North America where 81
percent of the respondents declare that
yes they have a ESG or CSR strategy and
that is very much aligned with the
results we saw for the audience of today
only nine percent in Europe uh declare
that they have no their organization
have no such strategy
the result in Mina are
aligned with those of America although
as I said in terms of methodology there
are a bit less representative of what's
taking place in these regions
now to complete
um the result of this short survey we
have also gathered information coming
from other industry research and from
reports produced by by the different
organization represented today the
different Council
the 2022 Gardner sustainability
opportunity risk and Technology survey
shows that 86 percent of business leader
see sustainability as an investment that
protect their organization from
disruption
four out of five leaders see
sustainability as helping their
organization optimize and reduce costs
and 83 percent say the sustainability
activity directly creates short and
long-term value for their organization
that's a little bit in contrast with the
results we've seen from the rank and
file employee of our Industries
organization when we we ask them a
question about this topic because they
seem to be far less
aware of this at least outside of Europe
far Westfall is aware of this question
than the leaders which were surveyed by
Gartner
and as we are in the ICT industry the
Telecom industry it's very interesting
to remind us that our industry is
responsible for three or four percent of
all Global carbon emissions
a telecom alone generating 1.6 of all
carbon emission that represents twice
the level of emission coming from the
aviation industry and and these data
come from the 2021 Boston Consulting
Group report
so it's an important topic for our
industry
and we think as fiber Centric
Association uh around the globe that
fiber is part of the solution
clearly fiber consumes less energy per
kilowatt
um and fiber material are inherently
sustainable
of course it's a passive infrastructure
and we'll see that compare with compared
to other Access Network Technology
fiber contribute to reduce
carbon output on the graph here and this
is coming from a fiber Robin Association
um consumers to study of last year you
can see that the
emission of CO2
per user when you compare the different
Access Network Technology
fiber to the home DSL hfc Network or
even Wireless
5G fixed wireless access
fiber is by far the one having the lower
impact in term of CO2 emission
and actually if I
combine that with information we we have
developed us here in Europe
we also see that this kind of picture
will only be confirmed if we move
towards gigabit type of connectivity
typically this number reflect the
situation and the bandwidth as it is
today if we were to extrapolate the
result at one gigabit it would require
um you know
um
for example hfc Network to move to
DOCSIS 4 with a much higher electrical
consumption and the the difference
between
um CO2 consumption of the different
technology will be even more in favor of
ftth
and it's not only direct emission which
is important what we also see is that
ftth can be essential to enable Telecom
Network to contribute to indirectly to
the reduction of carbon output this
slide show results once again coming
from the fiber bourbon Association
and what it shows is that typically what
we experienced during the pandemic and
the lockdown periods is that work from
home has a direct impact on the
reduction of CO2 emission and that
people are far more likely to work from
home if they enjoy a high quality
connectivity at home
the graph on the right shows that ftth
um
subscriber
have a higher average day working from
home than those which internet access
runs on hfc or DSL
so developing a high quality symmetrical
um ftth connectivity is one way to
trigger a behavior which are directly
impacting the reduction of carbon
footprint
it's now time for the second poll
so I will try and
launch this one if you bear with me one
second
you should see now the question and you
should be able to answer them
does your company have a greenhouse gas
emission Target
yes no I don't know I'll let you a few
seconds to to answer this to answer the
poll
um
I can see that we have 60 of the
audience now seventy percent uh voted
give you a couple of
um second to to complete the the voting
process thanks so much for for engaging
so rapidly with us
I think we are nearly there
I will close the poll and share the
results
so what we see is that in in in
coherence with your previous answer I
would say
um 50 of you uh say that your company
has this target uh
for 30 of you know and I don't know uh
20 percent
I think we are quite confident with what
we had on on ESG and CSR
policy and it shows that not only the
majority of the respondent declare that
they have a um a policy but also are
aware of specific uh Target when it
comes to carbon footprint for the
company so I think that's uh that's very
uh very interesting I need to
hide the pole and normally
we should be back on the slide deck
so it's clear that
our
our research shows very important
Regional difference and it will be very
interesting to discuss uh during the the
Q a part of this session
what is behind these differences in in
culture in maturity in approach of these
questions
um
we we see Europe as the exception if you
compare with the other region with a
clear high focus on sustainability
initiative more generally on all ESG
topic
North America is a little bit
surprisingly lying behind lagging behind
um
most server provider service providers
do not have a sustainability requirement
for vendors
moderate employment advancement Focus
again that's a point it which will be
very interesting to discuss with Gary in
the session later today
and with that
um I would like to to hand it over to
Juanita who will lead the the
conversation and the panel discussion
with us I would like before I do so to
to encourage you to use the question box
in the control panel to ask questions to
to the audience it would be great to to
get your view on the topic and address
any of your remark or questions so
thanks in advance for your participation
and Juanita the floor is yours
thank you Vincent yeah that's certainly
a very
very inter results so if all the other
my colleagues from around the world
collude if you will Peter Khan to join
us now for a quick panel discussion and
um glute
um
I'm going to start with you because
because you're a a woman so we get to we
get to do this
um so I wanted to just ask you about
sort of you know the findings from Amina
and um I'm gonna like you know ask like
why do you think like the environmental
part
um of uh you know the questionnaire is
sort of the most visible in the the
middle eastern North Africa region
well thank you so much Juanita for your
attention for the introduction and
explaining the results of the survey I
want to thank also all the attendees who
joined us today and thank you also uh
first allow me Juanita just to highlight
the results of the survey in mini region
um in the survey results in Nina region
we show strong bias towards the
environmental part in Mina region which
is a natural outcome of the government
or the government policies in the last
few years to raise the awareness about
the carbon footprint and a sustainable
development goals
um in Mina region they hosted two big
events last year in Egypt the cop 27 and
this year the cop 28 which will be a new
AE in November today is more the
awareness about the environmental issues
and the climate change and the world
um if I want to talk about the NCG
reporting in general in Mina region it
shows higher understanding of the ECG
and the large corporate with Telecom
operators or vendors probably influenced
by the result of mandatory uh ECG
reporting or lack of it for example in
Morocco Jordan
Egypt and UAE it is mandatory to issue
ECG report for all the public listed
companies and uh in Saudi Arabia Bahrain
Kuwait Qatar and Tunis the guidelines
are existed regarding the ECG report but
it is still voluntary to issue a ECG
report oh man it is on the way to issue
the guidelines regarding the ECG report
uh for the smes if we want to break down
the results more for the smes in general
are found lagging behind uh in terms of
reporting the ECG which is
very important to create the high
awareness or uh commitment and and and
employees however in my point of view I
see that the ECG growing as rapid uh
speed uh in the region as a small
country sorry countries are mandating
ECG reporting or hosting a global events
or Regional alliances
um for sustainability going back to our
question I think that in my view
our region grow up on stories of forest
lakes rivers that don't exist anymore
and all of this is a result of
desertification I came from Jordan and I
I can't remember very well how
urbanization damaged key natural sites
and I think the story can be found
across the region another reason is
sorry reason is that the water is truly
a limited resource in the region and
many places struggled with heat some can
imagine what climate change and and the
global warming is in our region that can
do so so people are more concerned about
the environmental side of of the ECG
reports more than any uh either more
than the social let's say or or
government so I guess that's why uh the
region in Mina is focused more on the
environmental uh site
yeah
um I can add to you
um and you know especially from Africa
point of view and especially in areas
where fiber deployments are relatively
new technologies that are being deployed
um in in a lot of cases there's a very
few
um initially very few uh or very little
respect for
um you know some of the methodologies
that are used to deploy infrastructure
and um uh you know even in the Africa
region we've had situations where people
had complete disregard for where they
drenched how they reinstated how they
acted
um you know in in you know relation to
the environment that they found
themselves in
um which meant and was that was like a
real negative impact on the sector
because it meant that government then
clamped down
probably harder than we would have liked
them to because they were just trying to
stop companies and from acting like
complete Cowboys you know and just doing
as as they please
um but what we found was that the larger
companies you know that had more um you
know that were that had more funding
available could then employ a specific
standards
um and you know work plans towards
sustainability it was the smaller
companies that came out and that
struggled with that
um do you find that the same um you know
you know in in minutes I listened to you
it does sound like the bigger companies
are putting in a visible effort
um and and how and when do you think
that this will actually filter down uh
to smmes and and can governments really
measure it
yeah foreign
I would say that it will eventually uh
follow with the ECG reporting let's say
a new AE the government now is starting
from January 2023 it is a mandate to a
ECG report in Saudi Arabia it's still
encouraging but it will come uh uh or it
will grow when we show or when the SM is
small smes uh see it as a beneficial uh
for them as a differentiator uh to their
customers like uh um the big companies
or big corporate including the Telecom
operators on and the public sector so uh
yeah as you said in in our region also
um the let's say the GCC uh countries
are more focused on sustainability
because of the fire the economic
situation there you know our region is
is not stable uh in so many countries so
I think uh the GCC countries are more
focused on on uh sustainability than
others
thanks Khalid and and specifically just
a focus on the telkom Telecom sector
um in the the Mina region how do you see
the Telecom sector adapting to the esgs
well let's agree that the technical
sector has a significant significant
role to play in terms of the
sustainability and reducing the carbon
footprint and achieving sustainable uh
goals it's because fiber optics it's not
only consumes less energy it's also uh
uh has a long lifespan in terms of than
other Technologies which reduces the
amount of waste so um in specific to our
case uh in Mina region recently we
witnessed an mou was signed by the most
uh major Telecom operators in gccu it is
a lot STC do Zen partial Co and and
omantel to join forces to boost ECG
awareness and Adoption of of
sustainability goals which is original
first I think we uh with more
partnership with uh learning trainings
we can see the Middle East taking more
major steps uh and more major role
towards uh achieving more sustainable
and prosperous future but um I would
like to focus again as Vincent mentioned
and and the presentation that uh one
more important step for uh the ICT
companies big companies uh is to invest
more in deployment of the fiber networks
because as we can see that compared to
other Broadband Technologies it's more
sustainable
yeah there's an old saying that goes
something like if you're not
intentionally doing it you're
unintentionally excluding it so it's got
to be a concerted effort uh you know
you've got to make a real impact and
potentially put your own mandate down as
a company to achieve esg's
um rusafi let's look a little bit at
Asia Pacific
um do you want to give us a little bit
more information and
um just a further explanation on the
level of maturity specifically in the
asia-pacific region
um you know as it was represented in
your survey
yeah thank You Juanita uh and thank you
uh to the fcga for uh having this
webinar uh I'd also like to thank all of
the attendees today uh so regarding the
Apex side uh though we have received
very low number of uh response uh from
the survey but based on that what we see
actually APAC is uh since APAC is a bit
of different
uh scenario kind of thing uh than the
other region so in our low number of
participation uh we saw that we have a
low percentage of uh the member
companies have PSG or CSR strategy
and high percentage have completed uh
carbon foot pain footprint and report so
overall I can see a bit of varied
application uh in terms of the real case
scenario on this topic as of now from
the member companies uh since there are
other challenges uh in our region and we
have around 52 countries in this region
so and we have developed Nations and
developing nations uh mixed together so
uh I think uh the most emerging Nations
have some other priorities uh to deploy
the infrastructure and other kind of uh
priorities to alleviate some of the uh
poverties from the economy So based on
that I think for these kind of things uh
the response was a bit low but at the
same time
yeah
for some of the like uh best uh like
like the following companies I think uh
it is a very good situation for them as
as uh Juanita and falood use told that
for the large scale companies it is much
easier for them to practice this kind of
uh uh good uh good practices so here
this applies in the same situation as
well uh I think overall that that was
the uh overview from my regime I have to
agree with you you know we sort of find
that same sort of apathy
um in subs or in Africa you know there's
so much still to do that
um you know often unless you're a
multinational or global companies often
esg's take sort of a back seat and
people are focused on deploying
infrastructure and navigating you know
the the passages and and trying to get
it right but
um do you do you think that you know
over time it'll change in your region
region you know do you think do you
think that there are countries that are
taking the lead that will Implement uh
policies in in the Apec region have you
heard any noises like that that they
will be a intervention at a government
level to introduce policies or do you
think that governments have got the same
sort of apathy which is why there's such
a small adoption
uh yeah so in in this question I think
uh I'd say that uh
down the line that that will come up
definitely but it will take a bit more
time like at least uh five six years
time because uh when actually the
developed Nations actually uh uh start
practicing this kind of stops and when
they open offices in the emerging
Nations so they want to comply with
these uh stops also but uh since they
have other priorities and there are lots
of bureaucracy and complications in the
government itself so it becomes a bit
delayed automatically so in terms of
that I think uh it will come up but uh
it might take some more time
in in terms of application
yeah and I speak for the African region
as well it's a shame because
um these emerging economies have got the
opportunity to do it right from the
start but it's simply not a priority
um which makes things uh really
difficult
um but just as a final question to you
maybe
um what is the fiber Network Council
your Apex work plan regarding
sustainability is it something that's on
the agenda as an association
um or do you sort of Take the Lead from
your members
yeah so uh since actually this webinar
was a kind of eye-opener for us as well
uh so that that was really a great
opportunity uh comparing region to
region it was definitely a huge uh blow
to us and uh I think from now on uh we
have our upcoming annual conference and
some physical events are upcoming and we
will try to uh
make make the events theme in a case so
that these sustainable wire actually
gets much priority uh for them or maybe
we will start some additional special
communication channels for uh this
sustainable things also so I think
definitely we will try from uh hour and
great thanks thanks and you are as a
fellow lagger I wish you all the best
it's not a it's not an easy topic to
touch and you know sometimes
um you know companies squirm and you
know feel like they've got a lot to deal
with but um Vincent
um I'm gonna come to you and um sort of
ask you the same question you know we
always are you know in I think in like
regions like Asia pack and particularly
sub-Saharan Africa I can speak you know
to sub-Saharan Africa I'm I'm currently
in Nairobi in Kenya and um I attended a
conference yesterday I actually chaired
the event
um and it's interesting how often Africa
Compares themselves to Europe and Africa
you know we often think that we should
be more like it or we could learn or
um you know but there's also a bit of a
thing coming out of Africa to saying you
know African solutions for African
problems and
um but at the same time you know there's
still a lot to be learned from Europe
and if I look at
um your survey results uh you know
naturally it's um you know makes some of
us hang our heads in shames do you want
to like give a little bit more input on
you know the level of maturity that we
particularly see in Europe uh this
service your esgs
yeah absolutely before I do so Juanita
let me uh just uh highlight something
for our audience we have
uh positioned the the pdf version of the
survey so the the document we produced
is available from
um the handout session uh of of this
platform so just for our audience if you
want to to read and get the detailed
information about the survey you can
simply download it from the handout
section of the um
of the panel control you must have on
your um on your screen so yeah
we we see higher level of maturity I
think this is probably cultural for
Europe there are multiple reasons
starting with the population being more
sensitive to this question of
environment you know we have we've had
for decades
um many political parties uh where where
the core Focus was ecology uh green
parties I've been in are in government
in multiple Coalition in Europe so they
have clearly that shows the importance
and the impact it has among the
population and it went up to the level
of the European commission so uh
starting from the EU and down to every
European government they are now clear
objective clear policy goals and clear
regulmentation uh and regulation so you
know that Europe is is champion of
Regulation uh we we pride ourselves for
um imposing standards and norms and
clearly on when it comes to this topic
of ESG a lot has been done and has
created that level of awareness among
the population starting with the
cultural and sociological basis which is
probably more sensitive to this question
in Europe than anywhere else
um we also
must say that the pandemics are
certainly accelerated that level of
awareness
um the war in in
um
in Russia and and the the consequence in
term of energy crisis has also uh being
a wake-up call just for us to realize
that we don't produce much uh fossil
fuel uh energy here in Europe we are
extremely dependent on uh Imports
um our production of coal gas and petrol
and oil definitely pass its peaked a
long time ago so we know that the more
it goes the less we will be able to
extract from European soil in terms of
fossil fuel energy so reducing carbon
emission also means reducing our
dependency uh on on Imports so the two
the two side of the coins are connected
and everybody I think now really
understands that it's not a question of
you know shall we go in that direction
but only how fast do we go we really
pass the the tip point in terms of
really understanding uh and putting that
in concrete action
um so that that's a big uh probably big
difference
um due to to the culture due to the the
history and and the physical constraints
we are facing
um you know that's really
um you know there's a lot to be proud of
um you know in Europe
um I think you know like not where we'd
like to be but we're not where you we
used to be
um kind of thing but um as an industry
Association
um you know obviously sometimes you know
the market and the members look towards
um you know some form of leadership in
this regard and uh you know putting out
statements or you know saying the right
things
um about the efforts that are being
applied you know with with these
impressive results
um as an association as a council the if
today's Council Europe do you have a
specific work plan regarding
sustainability and where you think you
should be going targets or or otherwise
well first of all maybe just a comment
um
I'm very happy that you you see Europe
uh as a leader but I would say that when
we look at our situation when we look at
um how early
we had all the information to indicate
the issue linked to climate change
um we could say also that we are very
late compared to the level of
information and the capacity we had and
the structure we had so I don't think I
mean I don't think we are necessarily an
example to follow uh and and we
shouldn't see as you know being in in
web in any way better than others we we
could have gone much faster uh with the
level of awareness we had of this issue
and and we have a difficulty of our own
um from that regard
um what is very clear as far as the ftth
council is concerned is that we have
seen a shift during the last two three
years whereby our members uh maybe you
know three four five years ago were
considering ESG as a nice to have
um you know maybe something of the
nature of a communication tool a little
bit of green washing it it looks very
nice on annual reports but we don't want
that that to cost too much that has
definitely changed now it's really
something which is super high on the
agenda uh in both rooms
CEOs are
um you know assessed on their capacity
to to concretely move the needle in the
right direction when it comes to ESG
um and it's no longer talking it's
really doing it and we really see that
that change taking place so we have a
sustainability committee focusing on
these questions one side of the action
is to use the benefits of fiber and to
emphasize the benefits of fiber when it
comes to sustainability and to what
extent fiber is the right choice if we
want to have a direct impact for our
industry but uh indirect impact for the
rest of the society
using all the the benefits of of high
speed connectivity to generate
education which overall reduce carbon
footprint
the second side of the coin is as an
industry we are developing a program to
help our members from the entire value
chain from manufacturers to operators
investors and the entire ecosystem are
on fiber to measure uh carbon footprint
in a very concrete way so we apply an
international standard we work with the
consultant we are putting together a
member of the ftth council to use the
same methodology to measure carbon
footprint and as you know in terms of
carbon footprint of an organization what
matters the most is what is called scope
3 which is the indirect consequence of
your activity in term of carbon
footprint so by putting together the
entire value chain we give the
possibility to
um company which are intertwined in the
ecosystem to exchange
good understanding of their respective
carbon footprint and increase in terms
of accuracy
um the the quality of their own
reporting on carbon footprint so that's
a huge effort we are starting uh
ultimately once that is put in place it
would help us measure the progresses and
also develop
um you know a communication around best
practices to to encourage everyone in in
our organization to go in the right
direction so that that's really the plan
we are putting in place
thanks um
conference and I I just need to
congratulate you a phenomenal event it's
uh really
um you know interesting and you know we
always like buy from your event with our
eyes to to learn how to do these things
and but um did you was there a conscious
decision to make sustainability a key
theme
um at the event and did its surface
um you know as as a theme during the
conference
I think we we actually passed that point
uh there are a session on sustainability
but what is even more interesting is
that sustainability is embedded in every
single discussion so there is not a
discussion on public policy a discussion
on operator strategy and ftth challenges
a discussion on uh investment where
sustainability is not surfacing and one
of the key issue so investors are
questioning uh very technical uh
regulatory issue about the taxonomy and
and why is ftth not yet identify as a
green investment that's a key concern
for investors operators are and large
operators all communicate about
Improvement they're making uh in their
trajectory towards
carbon neutrality I would say only the
the smaller operator some of the smaller
operators do not have a very clear
communication on that
and every vendor is presenting solution
concrete solution in time of product in
terms of architecture
trying to show how they reduce the
cupboard footprint of their products so
it's everywhere it's for vendor it
becomes a clear differentiator an area
of innovation but for everyone in the
value chain this is a topic which
um we we see as being part of every
single discussion so
um it's a theme but it becomes
um something which
interfere with every side of the
discussion we're having at the
conference
thanks Vincent I can't the chat box so I
don't know if there's any questions or
comments that I have not seen any
question and you know if you yeah maybe
I renew the
the invitation to to the audience to ask
any question if if you wish I'll be
happy to to relay That to You Juanita
thanks but um yeah otherwise yeah this
is really really
thank you again for taking the lead feet
on you know helping us you know develop
this this between yourselves and and uh
in North America I think that most of
the heavy lifting
um I think I'm going to move to some
closing comments um from all of our our
guests today khalude Vincent and rusafi
if there's
um you know just a closing comment that
you want to make around sustainability
um what that sort of means to you in
your region and
um uh you know what sort of effort you
think should be applied
I think in Mina region I do believe that
there is a lot uh to be done in terms of
sustainability we need more trainings we
need more more workshops we need the
companies the big companies and the smes
to to
make sure that their employees are aware
of the ESG to make sure that everybody
knows uh what sustainability is to apply
uh those criteria in their work and we
need to promote more I guess for
sustainability and to work more uh uh to
to
maybe promote for for for fiber also uh
more as as a sustainable tool or as the
most sustainable tool especially in the
big cities that are coming up now the
small cities that are coming up here and
in Mineral region so I think
um a lot has to be done but uh I believe
we are on the track
um
just touched on something um in closing
that I think is so important and I know
that
um you know Asia pack sub-Saharan Africa
we struggle with this these skills the
knowledge the um you know do we know
really understand sustainability is the
skill days the knowledge there to move
the the lever on on sustainability
yeah thank you uh Juanita yeah so it is
really a shame uh that uh though we are
the leader of the fiber deployment
across the globe and uh also most of the
fiber actually produced in Asia Pacific
region uh but still actually we we uh
couldn't actually follow the best
practices of deploying the fiber Network
fiber infrastructure and uh it's it's uh
really uh very unfortunate for us but uh
definitely here comes the same as fulut
told that a lot a lot to be done
and that's what we are trying here uh to
actually bridge the gap to bring
together the big uh and small companies
in a single umbrella to uh share and
exchange information and uh to actually
apply those in Real uh scenario so uh
that's what we're doing I think uh hope
in the coming days we will be definitely
uh see some light
thank you for uh
thanks and thanks for your time as well
today risafi
Vincent closing comments from your side
well I mean you mentioned that Europe is
ahead but I think it's just a a normal
uh thing for Europe to do because at the
end of the day we were the one
originally responsible for that level of
carbon emission and pollution starting
in the 19th century
and if you look at the cumulative impact
of Europe industry and and and
emission we are probably the the biggest
uh you know cause of of this climate
change crisis so
um
yeah we we should continue uh maybe lead
and and by example
um and take our responsibility because
clearly we are responsible for that
situation to a large extent uh certainly
much more than some of the country
recipe you mentioned in uh being still
struggling to develop and and get out of
poverty so um it's absolutely essential
that we we continue I think uh people
are in Europe are increasingly conscious
of uh of that challenge uh and working
on it but still a long way to go
um and as far as we are concerned in
term uh in our position of uh Council I
think we have a unique opportunity to
really move the needle in the right
direction
um our technology is in itself a part of
the solution for Telecom Network and by
providing the best-in-class Telecom
infrastructure we can also help
um our society adapt to
um
a level of organization which maintain a
minimum of prosperity while uh
addressing the the direct challenges of
of climate change so I think it's um
it's an exciting place to be to be able
to have a very positive impact on on our
environment
absolutely absolutely and it's amazing
how
um you're willing to take that
responsibility and to and to face it
here on and um I trust that you know the
other regions can can catch up as well
and or just Rusev do things differently
from the very beginning you know create
that awareness now and say you know
let's just let's fix it before we break
it so um yeah I just want to say thanks
to everybody for joining me today thank
you colleagues it's always nice to spend
some time with my fcga colleagues I
always say to my people this is this is
my team this is this is the people that
that I work with
um but Joe it's been great to spend this
morning with you
um thank you for your time my nervins
and you mentioned that it will be
available as we say in Nairobi or in
Swahili which means goodbye have a
wonderful day Vincent I don't know if
you want to just uh thank the audience
as the as the chairman of the fcga no
thank you we expect
um you know additional initiative from
the fcga in in the months to come we
keep on leveraging the benefit of
sharing the variety of experience we
have around the globe as you said in the
introduction of Juanita there is a 5 PM
CET session for for those who are in
that time zone and I think uh that time
slot has been socialized uh to to the
region concerned by
um by this webinar so um thank you very
much and I think the replay will be
available from uh from from the
different website of of our
organizations
thank you all
thank you thank you very much thanks
everyone have a nice day